[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
tél
[Musique]
la petite ville de coyote est à 50 km du
bois de la capitale conakry
la majorité des habitants ici n'ont pas
l'eau potable et de l'électricité
seulement un soir sur deux qu'à cela ne
tienne de plus en plus à la télé c'était
lui
pendant que les femmes cuisinent à
l'ombre de l'antenne chinoise sur un feu
de charbon de bois
les enfants s'amusent à imiter les stars
de tous les forfaits du fournisseur
chinois star times propose des chaînes
africaines européennes et des émissions
conçues à pékin je sais que tu vas
traduite en anglais en français et dans
un nombre grandissant de langues
africaines stratège c'est une chaîne tv
l'aimé beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est
parce que stratège il ya beaucoup de
séries puisque tu es un buggy new kiss
afrique est raffole des téléromans et
dix films de karaté offert par stalkers
mais c'est le prix qui rend le
fournisseur chinois
irrésistible moins cher - yamoussa à
payer seulement 45 dollars pour
l'antenne et le décodeur un équipement
que ce timbre offre parfois gratuitement
en guinée l'abonnement mensuel le moins
cher coûte 9 dollars par mois
on peut aussi s'abonner pour une seule
journée où il n'a ni la vision de
start-ups est de permettre à chaque
famille africaine de ceux de s'abonner à
la télévision numérique et d'enduire
donc
nous avons des bouquets qui sont déjà
taillé à leurs revenus quels que soient
leurs revenus
l'objectif officiel est de permettre aux
africains de rattraper la planète
numérique nous pouvons disons réduire la
marge de profits tout en donnant des
décodeurs aux clients afin de réduire à
cette facture numérique des prix
imbattables ont aussi permis à la marque
techno de devenir le plus gros vendeur
de téléphones intelligents en afrique
dans ce quartier de pêcheurs à conakry
même des annulations de familles
modestes ont un cellulaire
on peut trouver les appareils bas prix
comme ça paraît mais sa pop ça veut pas
faire un nom ou quelques mois ces jeunes
passionnés de basket ball passe
maintenant plus btan à jouer au ballon
sur leur écran que sur un terrain de
basket à l'aide de cadeaux et de gadgets
électroniques comme ce petit éventail il
a remis deux jeunes employés se promène
dans les lieux publics pour promouvoir
les marques techno intel et la bannière
bas de gamme de l'entreprise
enfin maquettes ou non voilà pour
aujourd'hui dans la commune me vois dans
la capitale et palau de techno un peu
partout les débats demain qui s'occupe
de la vente au détail
monsieur souvent a été un des premiers
jeunes vendeurs de techno en guinée où
tout début au départ franchement je n'y
croyais pas parce que de nous indiquer
les chnaoua des trucs qui sont pas
garanties donc ça dit que c'est pas bon
et qui brise facilement facilement et à
moins de trois mois six mois c'est fini
vous allez rester encore un nouveau
produit donc personne n'y croyait
techno a vendu 50 millions de téléphones
mobiles l'an dernier en afrique
ravissant le premier rang samsung kies
très loin devant warwick et à paul et
voilà comme on a contaminé toute la
rencontre et donc avec les bas prix avec
toujours avec les bas prix par rapport
aux biens chutent techno a vite compris
que pour beaucoup d'africains
la première qualité d'un smartphone est
de faire de bosser elle fuit les caméras
des téléphones ont été améliorés afin de
s'adapter au pont noir photo ça tout
matin avoue que les téléphones abordable
et les programmes de star times août
améliorer son opinion de la chine
la culture chinoise leur ballet les
trucs là que moi j'aime beaucoup
j'aime regarder d'enfants d'un carnaval
j'aime beaucoup ces trucs donc vous en
connaissez plus sur la chaîne maintenant
dans une prison chinoise aujourd'hui
dans les salons dans les coeurs des dix
meilleurs sept analystes politiques
estiment que les chaînes réussi avec ses
écrans bon marché à influencer l'opinion
d afrique plus ça marche super man ça
change de paradigme si avant on
percevait la chine comme étant un pays
pauvre
un pays émergent ces chaînes de télé la
diffuse plus tôt cette chine l'a7 chine
qui était aujourd'hui une puissance
ce père de cinq enfants touchent environ
40 dollars par mois
le pen appelait les abonnements de deux
smartphones et de la télé numérique
mêlent à des prix dérisoires en valeur
marama mounawar fit même monter mamou
faranah mannequin boisset limmat offrira
donc deux fois là on ira déjeuner débat
d'ennahda en réginald à sanaa noomane et
loue des n'a as far as pour le moment
encore le mont à nestlé
à ta maman j'aime le chinois tellement
je l'aimais tellement parce que c'est
peut-être par rapport à la loi qu'on a
eu beaucoup de soucis de moi j'ai envie
de refaire ce rise ça le vrai danger ce
qu'on a dit il utilise l'économie
pourrait influencer la culture des pays
en voie de développement
cet agronome et son épouse qui travaille
en communication craignent de plus en
plus l'influencé de la chine dans leur
pays et dans leur vitrine d'un gène au
moins une aliénation culturelle dans un
temps un autre
est ce que tu as appris des choses ou
les chinois le véritable danger que nous
constatons que nous ne pouvons pas
freiné leur avancée
surtout surtout leur programme le
contenu qu'ils nous envoient y on ne
peut pas aussi les biscuits les drogués
à un grand danger à l'avenir surtout
pour la jeunesse
[Musique]